hi
quick take so we just learned president
donald trump and the first lady have
been tested positive for coven 19.
this comes after hope hicks one of his
closest aides tested positive
joining me now is derek womback
bloomberg senior editor who has been
closely covering the presidential
campaign hey derek so tell us what the
latest is
hey groomie well you know look this is
the headline of the year
probably at this point and uh it's
shaken
a lot of people really really closely
because
the white house had been really trying
to set up a sort of bubble around
president trump
precisely to prevent this exact scenario
now
donald trump has said for a long time he
kind of wants the u.s to be going as
close to normal
as possible but there have been extra
protections
around the president they've been trying
to test people who come in contact with
him
uh but you know certainly earlier today
we learned
that hope hicks uh who is it was
arguably one of the president's closest
staffers
got coven 19 and then shortly afterwards
president trump tweeted he did too uh
so the president's going to isolate at
the uh at the white house melania trump
who he said
also uh got diagnosed with it will also
isolate at the white house and so that
is going to be going on now i don't have
to tell you
we're about a month away from the
presidential election
and so the stakes of this moment really
couldn't be
higher obviously you know we all hope
the best for the president and for his
family
um but but there is a lot of volatility
that's going on right now politically
yeah so you talked a little bit about
how he will be
quarantining right away so who is in
charge of his
self-isolation at the white house well
the thing with the president in the
united states is that generally the
president is in charge
of the president um donald trump runs
the u.s federal government
uh from an administrative point of view
uh
he has a lot of help from the white
house medical office so that
the attending physician is going to be
having a really big role to play here
uh the white house put out a memo from
that physician
uh earlier to sort of walk through
what some of these procedures are but
this is really sort of a
a white house driven thing it's not as
if like just because
the white house is in the middle of the
district of columbia that all of a
sudden the mayor of dc
has a state that really isn't the case
here it's very much the white house the
federal government
if he needs medical attention walter
reed medical center is right the way up
uh certainly uh the with the military
and the department of defense there's
going to be the best
doctors that the u.s federal government
has at their disposal
all of the top research in that will be
available to president trump as he goes
through that
now right now it seems like as you and i
are sitting here
discussing this it seems like you know
he's doing as open as he can be right
now
you know let's let's as i say let's hope
and pray that that stays the same
but if things were to get worse there
are a lot of resources and assets that
are at the president's disposal
so of course we are concerned about the
president but also the people around him
uh we saw vp pence a tweet this earlier
sending his love and prayers to donald
trump and his wife
melania trump but let's talk a little
bit about what happens
um to the people around him and the next
presidential debate
wasn't he pretty close in contact with
uh biden for example what happens next
well you're going to see an aggressive
contact tracing
uh system that's already underway uh you
will see people who are close to
president trump to pope hicks get tested
now that's going to wind up being quite
a lot of people in the white house so it
is theoretically possible
that there will be more announcements to
come it'll also include
some members of congress who have
traveled with
donald trump to rallies recently and
then
you know one of the key things here is
going to be
to try and figure out how big this
spread is is it just
that the president and his wife and you
know one or two senior staffers
uh got diagnosed with this or is this a
bigger thing and what sort of knock-on
effects
uh did that have so that's gonna be one
of the key things now
former vice president joe biden his
campaign has protocols
to try and keep him safe at the debate
uh donald trump and joe biden were
actually pretty distant one from another
they were standing
on separate sides of the stage they
didn't shake hands
at the beginning there wasn't like a lot
of glad handing going on now they were
in the same
hall not everyone on the trump side was
wearing
a mask uh so so there is some
question here but the biden campaign
will have a protocol for
what you would do if someone close in
proximity to joe biden
were to get diagnosed with coping 19 i
would imagine
we will hear from them uh hopefully soon
but i would imagine that those protocols
would immediately
start going into effect right we haven't
seen any
tweets for example from biden yet but
hopefully we hear uh something and
are uh we'll keep you posted on the
latest so thank you so much derek for
joining us our bloomberg
senior editor and thank you all for
watching a quick take make sure to
follow us at clicktake and at business
for all the latest updates and more stay
tuned bye for now